avec kenneth timerman ancien conseiller
aux affaires étrangères de donald trump
teza timmerman bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france peut-être
un mot sur votre sentiment aujourd'hui
après ces hommages à new york
écoutez
du président m'a
ému c'est a toujours décrit et durant sa
présidence d'être incapable de parler
d'être incohérent et en fait c'était de
la poésie il a parlé de notre âme en
tant qu'américains il a parlé de nos
meilleurs espoirs canton qu'américains
et en fait c'était un discours très
impressionnant impressionnant surtout
quand il a été suivi par servi de cadre
à le novice la vice-présidente
américaine qui a dit que l'unité était
une imposition l'unité s'imposer comme
si elle était à la tête d'un état de
dictature la dictature c'est à dire que
effectivement un appel à l'unité d'un
côté et et puis de l'autre on a entendu
le président donald trump qui a à
dénoncer l'incompétence de joe biden
dont la gestion du retrait des troupes
américaines d'afghanistan
mais évidemment et cela on en parle
depuis deux semaines ici trois semaines
c'est exécrable
by a fait à en hommage et la réputation
des etats-unis
la capacité de 10 soit d une attaque
contre les états unis cette façon
permanente de calibre aujourd'hui même
le 11 septembre a décrété le début de
son khalifat à kaboul c'est à dire qu'il
a célébré les attaques du 11 septembre
ont re en faisant rentrer au
gouvernement exactement les mêmes
personnes qui étaient là en 2001 au
début de tout site cette histoire bein
nous avait fait marche arrière de 20 ans
nous sommes également d'âge et le 10
septembre 2001 de talibans toujours au
pouvoir al quaida toujours
hébergés et est hébergée en afghanistan
et nous personne ne croit ne croit plus
à la dissuasion américaine un échec de
la politique américaine en afghanistan
on parlait il ya quelques instants du
patriot act qu'on est il sur le
territoire américain aujourd'hui où on
est finalement la menace terroriste est
ce que ce patriot act as a finalement
permis de lutter contre le terrorisme
sur le territoire américain
oui et non au début tout de suite après
2001 le patriot act a aidé parce qu'il a
permis de dépister les réseaux locaux
céder aux états unis qui étaient en
correspondance avec les réseaux d'al
qaïda à l'étranger mais il fallait
rejeter je supportais gt1 je soutenais
le patriot act
au début comme la plupart des hommes de
gauche et de droite aux otages et à
l'époque mais le henson et cia et des
autres la pia et aussi ils ont
par leurs propres actions ils se sont
discrédités et ils ont montré qu'il est
capable d'espionner tout le monde pour
n'importe quoi l'histoire le plus
accablantes c'était l'espionnite
contraintes dans trente durant campagne
de 2016 ils ont écouté pas seulement ses
communications électroniques s'est
téléphoné ces dames mais celle de tous
ses conseillers et de cette matériel
cette matériel de base ils ont construit
une panoplie de charges criminelles
contre un président en exercice du
pouvoir qui est incroyable et qui était
complètement d'ailleurs dé trouver ceux
d'hier ces accusations sont caduques il
n'est pas bien fondé et je pense
maintenant il ya plus beaucoup de
soutien pour le patriot act ni au
congrès surtout dans le public on arrive
à la fin de ce journal merci beaucoup en
tout cas kenneth timerman d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce soir en
direct sur rt franc je le rappelle vous
êtes ancien conseiller aux affaires
étrangères de donald trump